alors eric naulleau at il été trop loin
contre les paparazzi on va poser la
question déjà au principal intéressé
hamon eric vous avez votre carte mais
non enfin j'aime et j'ai pas le temps de
développer dans l'est c'est simple quand
on n'a pas assez de talent pour être
photographe on devient paparazzi c'est à
dire qu'on devient photographe de
caniveau mais non pas d'une mais ça vous
trompez j'ai donc en fer ont voulu faire
ça photographe de canal où je finis je
finis oui mais enfin vima en fait la
seule chose info les paparazzis sont aux
journalistes que les eaux usées sont à
l'eau courante pas d'accord 7000 kouakou
énorme et c'est via les égouts et les
égouts c'est les journaux que dirige
madame même rosanna vous êtes
vous êtes un violeur votre métier c'est
de violer l'intimité des gens contre de
l'argent vous vous avez des contraintes
évoquées avec alain soral c'est pas et
que vous venez de vous parler de la
racine épouse avaient eu des procès pour
leur part les bassa rapport parce que
son moral mais vous n'êtes pas dans le
genre le rapport non plus totalement
irréprochable j'ai publié des photos de
vous
n'avez pas les l'orientation sexuelle de
certaines personnes et des procès pour
ça donc vous pouvez faire ligne auront
fait que c'est de la diffamation oui
d'accord je n'ai jamais pensé que
quiconque ait jamais eu aucun procès je
peux vous dire c'est un mensonge assure
maîtriser des journaux montrent oui
c'est simplement continuer bastian
renseigner alors que monsieur
alain soral et on leur parle mais très
bien fait le point avec les sens de
changer l'orientation
conviennent au sujet alors éric elle
veut pas discuter du filet parce
qu'évidemment ça vous dérange dans leur
dit vous essayer à près de quelque chose
qui n'existe pas manger tous les dix ans
de procès
je fais juste nommé juste face à vos
contradictions non alors même oui mais
uniquement sur sur les paparazzi donc
pour vous on n'ait pas été outre aux
lois hier non ils sont payés pour violer
l'intimité des gens tout ce que les gens
veulent garder pour eux et leur vie
privée ils veulent que les gens qui
aient une vie privée soit désormais
privés de vie voilà votre but moi
j'estime qu'il ya une vie privée et une
vie publique l'une n'informe pas l'autre
je ne veux pas savoir ce que font les
gens qui sont aux responsabilités ou qui
prétend de responsabilités je le dois
pas savoir ce qu'il fallait on regarde
et on doit être intéressant toi et moi
et moi voyez je vous le dis en face je
ne me cache pas comme vous comme un
lâche dans l'ombre bon il faut que je
vous parle pas rapidement close alors
c'est vrai mais vous allez vous
vous dites ce team et ce n'est pas moi
qui
suis tapé sur l'eau je me suis dit cela
ne s'est jamais caché non non c'est à
dire que regarder sur les plateaux j'ai
toujours répondu aux interviews je me
suis juré qu'ils ont pas caché leur met
d'accord ou d'accord d'accord mais au
moins connu de brillants à la lumière en
parler j'ai pas honte de ça sachez vous
devriez faire des photos et que si j'ai
voulu être paparazzi c'est un choix et
c'est pas parce que je suis un mauvais
photographe j'ai fait plein d'autres
photos qui ont aucun rapport et peut pas
paradis et vous pourrez regarder les
traits sont pas pourris c'est un choix
on est est de traquer les gens je trouve
ça on est en haut des airs de l'inter on
est à l'époque des réseaux sociaux où
tout le monde raconte tout le monde sur
raconte tout sur sa vie où je faisais
rien patoche audi n'importe qui peut
être un paparazzi dans la rue faire une
photo de quelqu'un et que ça devienne
virale dont il y aura que les
journalistes ou les gens dont c'est le
métier qui n'auraient pas le droit de le
faire mais il faut il faut être humble
et l'intimité des gens si on est dans
une école en pierre d'intimité sébastien
rien on va vous donner à parler
j'aimerais bien avoir l'avis des
candidats ou parce qu'il ya que deux
noms donc deux qui sont d'accord avec
eric et il ya plusieurs oui jean michel
mr prouve êtes d'accord avec moi je suis
d'accord avec eric parce que comme il
vient de le dire un métier on est obligé
de se cacher pour l'exercer par
définition ça mais un métier dont on ne
doit pas être très fiers un meetic
quand on se cache pour faire son métier
c'est comme qui est un problème quelque
part entre c'est parce que si on veut
avoir des photos naturelles il faut pas
maintenant pas des photos naturelles
sont floues c'est pas des photos
naturelles et les photos de nous arrêter
ça fait longtemps quoi on sait mais
vous avez autant de trophées six ans on
sait la carte de journée
de pression mais je suis
aussi c'est pas intelligent on est le
seul pays au monde où il ya ce droit à
l'image c'est le monde vive la fema et
passera salomon jim avons rayé sablaise
obéit aux états unis en angleterre etc
les gens font des photos les les
journaux sont actuellement
middleton
chaque année j'avais sorti
c'est la ronde sonne c'est jamais sorti
non plus oui c'était moins fera la
longue vous avez été beaucoup prix - non
mais je fais de mon mieux avec lui
russell un partage des paparazzi c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de cacher
c'est trop loin le oui bien sûr ceux qui
étaient trop lents et le débat soit les
paparazzi c'est un vieux débat c'est pas
très nouveau ça fait des années
que je constate c'est que tu monte au
créneau parce que c'est la mode je n'ai
jamais entendu hurler au loup avant
l'affairé mots et là je m'étonne parce
qu'effectivement des paparazzades
dégueulasse il y en a eu
[Applaudissements]
les évêques de l'eau alors si je peux
finir pour la défendre eric naulleau là
dessus il sait déjà c'est pas du tarn
est un créneau pour d'autres personnes
comment est ce qu'on s'est retrouvé sur
un plateau ensemble on parlait de la
paparazzade de florian philippot vous
étiez très calme plateau avec vous
évidemment même florian qu'il faut c'est
sa vie privée qu'est ce que j'en ai mais
là vous étiez resté parce que j'en ai
mais j'étais sur le plateau en face
d'eux mais non là je vais pas m'énerver
un chapelet
et la concernant était réservé aux
nettement le concernant il est rentré on
va le dire en politique il est sur une
plage publique de photos qui montrent
mais non mais non mais non on parle de
ça il était barré par rapport à sa part
l'aider et je m'étonne effectivement je
trouve que ton indignation à la
géométrie variable voilà c'est pas mal
écouté
vous avez dit mais sur griveaux je me
suis exprimé sur des tas de gens tu te
trompes tout à l'heure j'ai galéré mais
n'avaient pas pris je voudrais voir
myriam non mais moi je je comprends ton
emportements à titre personnel et humain
moi j'ai été paparazzé c'est absolument
jennad bas avec mon amoureux j'ai rien à
cacher donc oui donc les faveurs mais je
n'étais pas contente je les dis
d'ailleurs même sur ce plateau je
l'avais dit je dois rattraper pas tant
parce que parce que ça met quelqu'un bon
ça dans la lumière qui n'a pas envie d'y
être peu importe pourtant y dom et je
fais un distinguo en deux épisodes j'ai
fait un distinguo entre la paparazzade
j'allais dire d'un lambda people parce
qu'il est sur une plage avec sa
maîtresse ou peu importe qui pour qui
pour moi n'a pas vraiment d'intérêt et
que je et dont je dis mais voilà enfin
un coq et voilà
mais d'une paparazzade politique qu'il a
pour le coup peut intéresser le citoyen
imaginons reprenons les affaires de
mazarine notamment etc on a ce sont des
affaires d'état on apprend que mazarine
a été élevé avec l'argent de l'état
qu'elle avait une protection rapprochée
donc moi je fais un distinguo et c'est
pour ça que je ne peux pas dire que tu
n'as pas été trop loin parce que tu as
mis tout le monde dans le même panier or
moi il ya ce que je trouve dégueulasse
qui est on s'en fout de la vie privée
d'un chanteur est en revanche les hommes
politiques moi ça m'intéresse parce que
ils ont un discours public qui est celui
de parfois de la morale et de la vertu
etc et ils peuvent être dans la vie
privée l'inversé ce qu'ils nous disent
tout à nous donc c'était de rené la
taupe
ce qui est quand même alors mario
palumbo est quand même assez énervant
c'est que eric zemmour danser dans ses
livres je peux vous citer des citations
fait l'apologie de l'infidélité donc en
gros bah oui oui je peux donner une
citation dans son preuve dans son lit
qui s'appelle le premier sexe plus on
adultes on respecte - en bande et il
évoque en évoquant stendhal et flo
vergne les cli les femmes devraient
remercier les hommes de les tromper avec
une [ __ ] ils dansent au moins piteuse
amant c'est l'éloge de la fidélité ça
d'annoncer la fidh et
prenez pas en contradiction avec ce
qu'il dit dans ses livres donc quelle
est l'information non mais alors
pourquoi vous êtes choqué qu'on constate
le vitoria il devrait y avoir une limite
excusez moi alors je doit débattre avec
deux personnes dont une se vante de
faire un métier où il doit se cacher et
vous qui commençaient à lancer des
accusations complètement fantaisie sur
un procès pour orientation sexuelle est
tué renseignez-vous ouais bien sûr
renseignez-vous nombreuses années et
dont les retourneurs au torchon
par les autres noms mais ce que non non
non j'allais vous calmer parce que bon
minutes je ne vais pas me lancer des
accusations et
oui bien sûr vous voulez tout ce qu'on a
donné de très intelligent il nous sommes
très idiot on a bien compris votre
message merci beaucoup touchent mais
vous n'avez pas l'air de bruit
on a hérité eric thoniers eric de newtec
les attaques eric technique vous êtes un
proche de sarah knafo vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la publication
livre noir et est ce que est ce que sa
qualité sa réaction à à sarah donc la
jeune fille qu'on voyait qu'eric zemmour
quand elle a vu c'est parce qu'elle est
épais dont le nom n'est pas cité sur la
couverture un peu sexiste non là dessus
et complètement raison
aujourd'hui est là c'est là un fort
caractère mais qu'elle est
indéboulonnable donc là dessus ça ne
sonne n'atteint pas ça ne changera rien
toute façon à la suite des choses moi
pour rebondir sur ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure je fais la seule
différence que je fais c'est entre les
magazines public voici dont on sait
depuis longtemps que ce sont des
torchons alors ça c'est à dire c'est la
patronne de public oui oui exactement
oui j'ai découvert tout à l'heure je ne
lis jamais ce magazine je ne vais pas
acheter parce que j'ai pas envie de
donner de l'argent pour ça je suis assez
scandalisé parce que votre site je
regarde pas votre site
votre journal à son psy parce qu'on peut
emballer le poisson avec vos journaux
alors qu'avec son site on pleure il
fallait bateau mais tant que public et
une utilité pour vous voilà je suis est
alors la différence avec paris match
faut savoir que la journaliste politique
de paris match qui a rédigé l'article
emilie la nes moi je vais au téléphone
en préparant cet article d'accord je
l'eus 55 minutes et 45 secondes pour
être très beau ici où on a parlé
effectivement de sarah knafo de son
idéologie de son parcours extérieur
parce que je la connais bien et vous
savez ce qu'elle m'a tenus comme propos
au milieu de la conversation elle m'a
fait un tunnel pendant cinq minutes en
m'expliquant que ça serait scandaleux
qu'on s'attaque à sarah knafo sur sa vie
privée qu'on soit match au point de
faire comprendre que finalement il n'est
pas là parce qu'elle est intelligente et
brillante mais que finalement et bien
elle aurait des relations sexuelles et
intime et c'était absolument hallucinant
et vous savez j'en ai parlé avant d'être
piégés
en fait moi je toute façon je ne je ne
connais pas la vie intime de sarah on a
une relation plutôt d'amitié politique
c'est ses affaires ça ne me concerne pas
donc je n'avais rien à lui donner là
dessus mais je suis sorti de ce coup de
téléphone en me disant c'est une bonne
journaliste et je pense que des gens se
sont fait piéger déontologiquement quand
on arrivait qu'on ait un journaliste
politique comment qu'on manipule je
trouve que c'est scandaleux ce que vous
a dit ça quand elle couvé quand elle a
découvert le paris match et bien
justement je vais vous citer mot pour
mot elle m'a raconté exactement ce qui
s'était passé lors de sa conversation
avec emilie de la nes et milliers de
l'analyste exactement elle lui a proposé
de parler en off savez dans près des
journalistes souvent il ya du off donc
est là elle a accepté il ya eu une
vision est en fait déjà un il vient
cette journaliste sa grille un off mais
surtout la journaliste qui a tenu le
même discours que près de moi alors je
vais vous citer exactement ce qu'a dit
la journaliste elle a dit à sarakhs napo
je trouve ça tellement misogyne les gens
qui parle de vous comme la meuf d'intel
ou la meuf d'intel moi je sais que vous
êtes remarquable et brillante je trouve
ça indigne que des gens vous attaque sur
le mode de la vie privée alors soit on
la leur et exceptionnellement
intelligente cette journaliste parce
qu'elle sait pertinemment que vous avez
un métier pourri soit helmand elle
manipule je ne comprends pas bien senti
lors je ne suis pas là pour faire je
suis pas la rédaction de paris match ils
ont leur façon alors j'ai pu photo donc
nous on n'a pas du tout travaillé comme
ça alors si aulas journaliste
interviewer et qui vous interviewez
s'est fait passer pour une journaliste
politique bien l'aimer les canons
samantha cas des conseils pour la
manipulation non mais c'est tombé dans
la manipulation est très lourd ce qui me
scandalise c'est que vous avez vous eu
quelqu'un au logiciel est ce que nous je
venais papiers pas d'argent je dois
prendre des photos je comprendrais si je
pouvais je l'enseigné
vous que vous en avez trop fier non sa
ceinture non je suis fier du tout vous
quand vous parlez vous êtes en train de
bonne chère vous c'est le très fier du
travail que vous faites vous mais bien
sûr je suis fier du travail protégé des
équipes derrière et je les défendrai
coûte que coûte mais vrac assez dense
donc serait pas bon vous savez combien
les responsables
il a comparé par parents mais bahougne à
cons on est à peu près de nous on
représente la presse people ça
représente 9% du mât d'une part de
marché sur combien de gens qui se
droguent nom d'yves les dealers alors
j'aime pas faire ça j'aime pas attaquer
vous est d'une bêtise a commencé qu'elle
était là pour l'été l'intérêt de faire
genre de show donc j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure ça râle argumentation et télé
devient employé sarah knafo et eric
zemmour déambuler pas tous au bord de la
borde de la plage en sortant du meeting
demain c'est sa conseillère on a le
droit il ils vont se réunir ensemble
dans l'oise il laisse les gens qui se
promènent sur la plage mais danseurs des
photos avec son téléphone portable par
les qataris auraient pas le droit de
faire de foire n'est pas de ce monde ira
à saint lyé des moments il n'en laisse
les idéaux qui au ps où le système
frêche sur le balai chez foot
voilà on veut dire des photos
pascal et la fonction d'un journaliste
people même si de la plupart des gens
autour d'une contradiction jean nice
people oui on d'accord jean à la carte
alors allez journalisme de caniveau
non mais vous êtes toujours dans la
boîte faudrait
qu'elle est là qu elle est là la vole à
la mission d'un journaliste people ces
deux effectivement révélé la vie privée
des people il s'avère que eric zemmour
est au devant de la scène et c'est pas
nous qui le mettront devant de la scène
donc nous en tant que journaliste people
nous révélons sa vie privée parce que
c'est qu'un people c'est vous qui
transforme et ça fait plutôt que je fais
ce que je veux avec mes photographié
dans des
couvertures ok mais mon pantalon devant
devant c'est quoi placer le couple a
deux enfants weezer gala donc d'accord
donc chargé me voilà
dit strictement rien à me reprocher donc
nous c'est vous qui fait de l'idéologie
politique parce que nous que la soie
zemmour que ça soit hollande que ça soit
sarkozy à partir du moment où notre
mission enfin notre notre rôle c'est un
bien beau mais on révèle en même temps
que des fois la vie privée e mail révèle
certains aspects de la personnalité des
mains de quelqu'un qui se présente aux
élections electro élections
présidentielles essentielle pour les
développeurs et c'est la vie privée des
gens françois mitterrand a fait ordonner
des milliers d' écoute à dépenser un
argent et non pour cachée mazarine vous
trouvez ça normal c'est de l'argent
public
pour cacher
c'est bon c'est la
vie pour les proches d'eric zemmour est
ce que c'est une vraie paparazzade ça
parce qu'aujourd'hui à plusieurs
journalistes alors qu'ils ont dit que
c'était une demi paparazade disque est
celle qui sent bon sens sous entendu
qu'en fait il se cachait à moitié ont
été opposées sont au final ça l'arrangé
d'être en une de paris match et qui joue
la victime aujourd'hui mais j'ai discuté
avec les deux intéressés c'est
absolument inadmissible d'insinuer ça on
la continue il soit si ça a été insinué
que j'apprenne accueilli hier par
certains participants par des
journalistes pardonner mais a été dans
libération il ya un article absolument
scandaleux ou sous prétexte de
s'interroger en fait on affirme je
trouve ça scandaleux ils ont été piégés
peut-être par imprudence et non en
aucune manière participé à cette
paparazzade j'ai déjà quelques pièces de
jour béarnaise gilles verdez govou et
eric naulleau était trop long trop
beaucoup trop loin eric naulleau je vous
comprends pas du tout pour deux raisons
d'abord c'est du vrai journalisme qui
font les paparazzi et ça a un sens et en
plus il faut pas être naïf quand vous
vous lancer en politique quasiment
campagne moi je me souviens j'ai le fils
d'un candidat qui m'avait dit on à notre
famille a implosé lorsqu'il s'est mis à
être candidat notre famille était
détruite vous le savez quand vous vous
présentez ou quand vous êtes sur le
point de vous présenter il ya des photos
qui sortent donc je suis persuadé mois
que zemmour savait que ce type de photos
érotiques folie de croire le contraire a
été trouvé sur la médiation ces fonds
avec naulleau c'est faux ce que vous
aimez ces faits sont avérés c'est
l'équitation qu'ils savaient et je vous
certifie ici tu ne le savais pas si
possible
avec ça devait arriver un jour louis les
liqueurs pour ses 10 46 et les deux le
savoir on sait que ça peut arriver et
vous savez pourquoi il le ils le
savaient pas parce qu'ils sont pas dans
le même monde que vous
jamais
la même chose vis dans un autiste et
dans la magazine de vivre son côté
mireille
jean leymarie dans le cas jean michel
maire demande à myriam parce qu'elle
trouve qu'il sait mieux c'est tout à
fait normal et sain de de diffuser des
informations privées sur les people
comme ça si quelqu'un aujourd'hui à des
photos compromettantes sur toulouse
j'accepte sur vous vous acceptez qui les
met sur un blog par exemple
diffuser les photos qui
t'ont moto cocotiers fort les fesses
propres
en même temps quand vous dites ça il ya
quelque part sous préfet ce que c'est un
homme politique je sens une menace
derrière tout ça bah non je vois de
photos non mais voilà donc non conseil
ménages
signifiante pasionaria il a même pas
d'infos sur l'émission crois pas qu'il a
des photos sur toile bien sûr mais
l'enjeu n'est pas bien sûr est que vous
savez qui a pris cette photo c'est un
photographe qui l'a suivi pendant toute
cette année officielle voilà de manière
officielle dont cécile moi ce que je
vous dis ils ont fait confiant il ya
suis ont fait confiance mais on devrait
pas faire confiance alors on va voir si
on commence à voir les spectateurs est
ce qu'ils seront pas dans le même louis
à 48% dans le maine 1 52% voilà sinon
quand même raison sinon il ya seulement
neuf cent mille sont pas tout à fait
d'accord avec les et chroniqueurs autour
de la table